[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to "I/O Live."
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I'm standing here
with Nile and with Shaza.
And they built an
app using TensorFlow.
We're going to talk
about it a little.
Nile, could you tell
me what the app is,
and how you came
up with the idea?
NILE RAVENELL: Sure.
So the app is actually a
plant classification app.
You basically take your camera
and hold it over a plant leaf.
The app then tells you
what type of plant it is.
It tells you if it's healthy
or if it has a disease,
and what the disease is.
And we actually came up
with it one day in lunch.
So Shaza had been talking
about wanting to create an app.
And we were
brainstorming some ideas.
And I thought about
my mom, who has had
a huge passion for gardening.
About a year ago,
we ended up moving.
And so she had to transport
her garden from a big backyard
to a tiny little
patio on an apartment.
Thus, all of her
plants were dying.
So we ended up making the
app and helping her garden
flourish.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Now, Shaza, what
was it like getting
started with machine learning?
SHAZA MEHDI: Hi, Timothy.
I got started with machine
learning through a TensorFlow
Codelab called
TensorFlow for Poets.
And I learned all about
how machine learning works
and how to use convolutional
neural networks
on your own dataset
using the Tentacle API.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Did you
find that challenging?
SHAZA MEHDI: It was
very challenging.
It took me a long time to
learn because it was my very
first programming experience.
But I ended up doing a
really amazing project.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Now, what's next?
Do you have any
ideas for new apps?
NILE RAVENELL: Yeah.
So I definitely
want to do something
that has to do with women
in third world countries.
I have a really close friend who
is actually a national leader
in the organization Girl Up.
And so their topic is
just dealing with women
in third world countries.
So we're definitely working
together right now on something
to benefit that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
OK, one last question.
Do you have any
advice for somebody
out there who's looking to get
started in machine learning,
or even just computer science?
SHAZA MEHDI: To
someone who's looking
to get started in
computer science,
I would tell them that it's
a lot easier than you think.
And there are a ton
of resources out there
if you want to learn
about machine learning
or artificial intelligence.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
And thank you for joining us.
This is "I/O Live."
[MUSIC PLAYING]